Friedrich Merz hat ein echtes
politikdefizit Politik ist Kommunikation
er kriegt es nicht in Dinge zu sagen so
wie sie gerade gesagt haben natürlich
ist es gesellschaftspolitisch sinnvoll
vielleicht ein selbstbestimmungsgesetz
zu machen vielleicht kann man auch eine
Cannabis Legalisierung machen aber die
drängenden politischen Themen sind eine
Wohnungslosigkeit ist eine Migration und
Wohlstand einverstanden kann man doch
alles sagen ohne auszugrenzen warum muss
dieser Mann bei jedem Auftritt
irgendwelche Gruppen oder Städte oder
gesellschaftliche Bewegungen ausgrenzen
warum kann ein Oppositionsführer nicht
priorisieren die Themen und Menschen
zusammenbringen ist das per se nicht
amtsbeschreibung von Friedrich Merz
meine These ist der ist viel zu lange
weg gewesen aus der Politik das ist euer
Problem der weiß gar nicht wie man
kommuniziert
ich kann das schon ich mache das schon
und wir sind hier nicht bei mir kennen
sie wir sind nicht in so einer
wirtschaftsrunde wo man mal eben einen
raushauen kann irgendwie und dann gibt's
Applaus weil ich der CEO bin so kannst
du in der in der Politik gerade in so
einer Krise Situation so kannst du nicht